Thanks to the President of the Republic
under the presidency of the European Union,
which we were able to do when France had the honor of being in charge,
I had to carry the decisions of our country in migration matters,
bring to a conclusion a migration pact that has been blocked for 10 years,
which provides for the systematic
registration of foreigners arriving on our soil,
asylum controls,
finally at the border of the European Union,
and help our Maltese,
Greek,
Italian and Spanish friends.
1. Europe,
solutions since everyone understands that the migration issue
is above all a global issue that is settled between continents...
Let's vote for the National Rally against the shenken
revision which re-establishes for the 1st time sustainable
police controls in our border areas and which allows our country,
France,
as well as all European countries,
to release them in case of terrorist threats for our security...
Let's vote the National Rally against
Why?
Because the RN lives problems and does not want any solution.
Because if there is no more problem,
there is no more National Rally.